in this lesson we're going to talk about
retrosynthesis which is basically
synthesis in Reverse we know a target
that we wish to make and we need to go
backwards and think about how we'll make
it from things we can buy so we'll start
with a pretty simple molecule to
introduce some terminology and some
concepts this is our target molecule and
we want to think about how to make this
from commercially available chemicals
and so we're going to use an arrow that
allows us to show that we're thinking in
Reverse this is the retro-synthetic
arrow or a retrosynthesis arrow so
here's our arrow and we want to think
about breaking a bond for this example
I'm going to cleave this bond next to
the ether so I've drawn a little wavy
line to show that this line is called a
disconnection and what we're going to do
is we're going to draw each side of the
molecule without thinking about the
reagent or chemical we're going to use
we're just going to break this bond and
draw what we get now we need to think
about the polarity that each of these
partners will have assuming that we have
a polar reaction that's going to happen
to form this and we're forming ether and
you might remember there's the
williamson ether a'f ocation reaction
that allows us to form ethers well first
of all I'm going to assign polarity but
I'm gonna do it in the wrong way just to
show you and then we'll do it the
correct way now say I thought this had
to be nucleophilic I would draw this
which is called a synth on with a
negative charge here so now as this is
negative well this would have to be
positive now this kind of polarity on
these molecules which which are
synthesized reagents to just show what
would be a nucleophile and what would be
an electrophile they might correspond to
an intermediate along the path but they
are not real reagents but these aren't
very good look at oxygen we have a
positive charge on it we think of oxygen
typically as a nucleophile the lone
pairs on oxygen attack things and here
we'd have to have some sort of grignard
with another bromine in it
this is not the natural polarity that
this type of reaction would take on so
if we did this and set this up as our
sentence we should notice that oxygen
being positive and getting attacked that
doesn't really happen let's redraw them
with the correct polarity here are our
correctly drawn sentence the oxygen has
negative charge this is natural oxygen
tends to have negative charge and this
more electro positive carbon has
positive character in our sentence the
nucleophilic partner this one is going
to be called our donor sent on it
donates the electrons and this one will
be the acceptor alright now I can't go
to sigma-aldrich and find synth ons I
just can't behind these things I need to
buy reagents so what could this
translate to well this one is pretty
easy it has an own - but we know that
fin all pretty readily available maybe
from our electrophilic aromatic
substitution chapters so here's fennel
and then something like this would need
to have a leaving group on it so to have
carbon to have positive character
something that's a inductively electron
withdrawing will give that positive
character and if the leaving group
leaves we form a carbo cation of course
this is a primary carbo cation but
remember this is a synth on this is just
a device to help us think about what we
need to put together so maybe we could
have just a bromide on this side as well
and one of the bromides will leave in
our reaction our reagent will be this
one to die bromo ethane here in this
example I told you we wanted to cleave
this bond this is a pretty good rule
cleaving next to a hetero atom so if we
can cut a bond and think about a
reasonable reaction that we know from
all of our organic chemistry to make
this bond in ether linkage that's great
but there are a couple places that are
next to these hetero atoms that I didn't
cleave and I want to show you why before
we move on to lots of reactions and
examples here's our target molecule
redrawn
now I'm going to draw some other
disconnections will cleave on the left
side of the ether and call this a and
then we'll disconnect adjacent to the
bromide and call that B okay neither of
these is a very good disconnection so
why not with a if we're capitalizing on
the natural polarity of oxygen to be
negative and a nucleophile we're gonna
end up with an aryl cation let's draw
our sentence
now this Errol cation might look
familiar from the diazonium reaction so
these can be formed but they're really
high-energy and this is kind of a
difficult reaction this isn't the
natural polarity of an aromatic ring now
if we had electron withdrawing groups on
here we could think of maybe a
nucleophilic aromatic substitution
involving a positively charged area on
an aromatic ring but for this
unsubstituted ring that doesn't really
apply so there's no reason we do
nucleophilic aromatic substitution doing
a diazonium reaction is not as reliable
as the Williamson a theraph ocation so
that's why a would not be our best
disconnection okay why not be alright so
we just broke the bond we haven't put on
our polarities yet but bromine usually
has a negative charge BR minus is a good
leaving group a good nucleophile so
let's assign that polarity to this synth
on now we need a positive charge here
okay what we saw we could do that carbon
is an electro positive atom and we came
up with something like this so why would
we put a leaving group on a carbon just
to replace it with another group that
doesn't simplify our synthesis at all we
already need to have all of this built
up if we were adding on the bromine and
a last step so this doesn't make sense
either so our best disconnection is
cleaving here to the right of the hetero
atom and using the negative charge of
oxygen and perhaps a Williamson ether
synthesis now we can draw a forward
synthesis beginning with phenol we can
treat this with base perhaps sodium
hydride and then add in our bromide and
this should give our target molecule
this analysis is going to work for
sulfur 2 so let's make this count
very similar to this one will disconnect
in the same place and now I want to
introduce a little terminology that we
can write above the arrow we can tell
what bond were cleaving and here it's a
carbon sulfur bond so we write CS like
this up here we can write Co and
sometimes we'll put the functional group
name as well so Co and making an ether
CS I could put Phyo ether sulfur is a
good nucleophile and sn2 reactions so
that has the negative charge we have the
same bromide and so let's show what
reagents we might be able to use these
are both commercially available
compounds we have the sodium salt of
this dial phenol here so this is an S
minus na plus you can buy it as the salt
from sigma-aldrich and it's useful
there's a webpage you can go to the
sigma-aldrich structure search which
allows you to put in a structure and
search for similar structures or that
exact structure and see if you've gotten
your synthesis back to commercially
available compounds let's try an example
with an amine and see if it'll work out
the same although this is a pretty
simple looking molecule it is not
commercially available and so you might
think oh I could probably substitute
this amine for maybe a leaving group
maybe a halogen so that would be a
different transformation we're not
really breaking a bond we're just
changing a functional group so let's
introduce another bit of terminology
we're going to write FG over the arrow
to show this would be a functional group
conversion now the corresponding bromide
is commercially available and we might
think about reacting this with ammonia
but this reaction has a big problem
once we alkylate we add nitrogen in and
get that on to the molecule forming this
product this product is actually more
nucleophilic than ammonia there is a
added electron density so there's this
inductive electron donating effect from
the alkyl group so this compound is more
likely to react with another molecule of
bromide the pneumonia is to react with
it so you can see the problem
we'll get more than one group on here
and we can't really control that so for
a means this is not a viable route due
to over alkylation but we have a couple
solutions for this the first solution is
a reaction called reductive amination
this is where we take the corresponding
carbonyl compound which in this case is
this aldehyde react it with ammonia and
we'll get an amine this is not typically
isolated but it's reduced with sodium
borohydride or hydrogenation and that
will form our target mean the second
solution to the over alkylation problem
is to make the Amman and then reduce
that a Mnet's are formed very smoothly
by the reaction of an amine with an acid
chloride and this can be treated with
lithium aluminum hydride to form our
target molecule now this acid chloride
is actually not commercially available
but I looked it up and the acid is so
just with the O H here we know that we
can treat carboxylic acids with thionyl
chloride and form the acid chlorides
smoothly so we have a route to this KP
here if you learn something give me a
thumbs up on the way out and for more
chemistry subscribe to my channel